did you know that I tried to become a
pro wrestler and failed spectacularly
but not in the way that you think I did
I was 22 years old three years deep into
college and then I decided to drop out
and I found myself really with no
direction in life I'd be a massive fan
of the WWE for the longest time and
always wanted to try it out I took a
full year to put on as much muscle as I
possibly could much more than I do now
and it worked who knew training actually
pays off from that point on I sought out
rest in schools in my local area and I
did find them I would train in my city
twice a week and then once a week I
would go up to Dublin via a three-hour
train ride to train with none other than
Joe cabray who at the time had just
finished a brief stint with WWE's
developmental a place where I wanted to
go so he was the perfect person to teach
me stuff I was 200 pounds at the time
lean 23 years old tall enough for the
WWE at 6.1 and I decided to after a year
of training reserve a spot in landstorms
academy for wrestling